well we're all arguing about Stormy
Daniels big things are happening biggest
of all is life expectancy in the United
States going in the wrong direction one
of the drivers of that is Health
Americans have a lot more chronic health
issues than they used to very few people
have commented in this or thought about
why it's happening Mark Hyman is a
physician and the exception to this
really an amazing person if you're not
familiar with him he's got a new book
out called Young Forever the secrets to
living long healthy lives we talked to
Mark Hyman on many recommendations
you've got to talk tomorrow so we did
for a brand new episode of Tucker
Carlson today here's part of it
[Music]
we have developed a medical system based
on historical phenomena which is you
have a headache you go to the Head
doctor you have a stomach ache you go to
the stomach doctor it seems logical
except biology isn't organized that way
it's not the way the body's organized
the body is a system so rather than
treat each individual part each
individual symptom we treat the root
causes and we create health so
functional medicine is the science of
creating health
as opposed to signs of treating disease
and when you create health disease goes
away as a side effect we have our whole
concept of disease wrong that it's some
entity a thing that we catch like a cold
yes yes that's exactly right but it's
not like that like someday you just get
it yeah I get heart disease or I got
diabetes or I get cancer I get Dementia
or I get whatever autoimmune disease no
there are really clear causes for these
problems that are rooted in things that
we now know that we haven't translated
into medical practice and for every 10
of your calories is ultra processed food
your risk of death goes up by 14 and our
diet is 60 Ultra processed food and kids
is 67 percent
it's a national emergency honestly I
mean there's six million people that
died from covet globally but 11 million
people die every year from bad food
that's an amazing conversation even if
you love pizza and Oreos as some of us
do Dr Mark Hyman tomorrow 70 I'm on Fox
Nation you can stream it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight